el objetivo del vídeo es usar este
simulador desarrollado por charlotte
hour para comprender mejor los
intervalos de confianza aquí tenemos una
máquina de dulces que tiene cierta
proporción de dulces verdes vamos a
establecer esta proporción al 60 por
ciento e imaginemos que alguien más usa
esto y no sabe que la proporción es de
60% sin embargo puede tomar muestras
digamos que toma muestras de 50 dulces a
la vez toma una muestra y la proporción
muestral es 0.62 toma otra muestra y
ahora la proporción muestral es 0.64 es
decir que el 64% de esos dulces
resultaron ser verdes éstos son
diferentes estimados pero para cada
estimado que confianza tenemos de que la
verdadera proporción de la población se
encuentre en cierto rango alrededor del
estimado si vemos esta pestaña veremos
representados los intervalos de
confianza en un vídeo anterior vimos
cómo calcular el intervalo de confianza
en el simulador tenemos que el nivel de
confianza del intervalo es de 95% este
es el valor típico que usan las personas
por lo que tenemos una probabilidad del
95%
que cualquiera que sea la proporción
muestral este se encuentre dentro de dos
desviaciones estándar t la proporción
verdadera también podemos decir que la
proporción verdadera estará contenida en
el intervalo de dos desviaciones
estándar a ambos lados de la proporción
muestral si no conocemos la proporción
verdadera la forma en la que estimamos
la desviación estándar es con el error
estándar como lo hemos visto en vídeos
anteriores estos son dos errores
estándar a la derecha y estos son dos
errores estándar a la izquierda de la
proporción muestral el intervalo de
confianza es todo este intervalo desde
este punto a la izquierda hasta este
punto a la derecha y conforme tomamos
más muestras podemos ver aunque no es
obvio que los intervalos cambian
dependiendo de dónde se encuentra la
proporción muestral pues usamos la
proporción muestral para calcular los
intervalos de confianza suponemos que
quien realice los muestreos no conoce
cuál es la proporción verdadera de la
población algo interesante de esta
simulación es que podemos ver el
porcentaje de las veces que el intervalo
de confianza contiene al parámetro
verdadero vamos a tomar 25 muestras a la
vez aquí podemos ver que el 94% de las
muestras en el intervalo
confianza contienen al parámetro
verdadero de la población podemos seguir
tomando más muestras y veremos que
mientras más muestras tomemos más nos
aproximamos a que el 95% de los casos el
intervalo contenga al parámetro
verdadero de la población en un vídeo
anterior desarrollamos las matemáticas
pero ahora podemos ver que los
intervalos de confianza al calcular los
como lo hemos establecido se comportan
adecuadamente y cumplen con su cometido
si calculamos un intervalo de confianza
con base en un nivel de confianza del
95%
tendremos que aproximadamente el 95% de
las veces el parámetro verdadero de la
población se encontrará contenido en ese
intervalo si tomamos más y más muestras
veremos que esto se cumple aunque de vez
en cuando tendremos una muestra para la
que aún cuando calculemos el intervalo
de confianza el parámetro verdadero de
la población no se encontrará contenido
en dicho intervalo pero esa es la
excepción que ocurre muy pocas veces
pues el 95% de las veces el parámetro
verdadero está contenido en ese
intervalo otra cosa interesante que
podemos ver aquí
es que si incrementamos el tamaño de la
muestra el intervalo de confianza se
hará más pequeño vamos a aumentar el
tamaño de la muestra a 200 y ejecutamos
algunas muestras vean que los intervalos
de confianza son más estrechos pero aún
así debido a que el nivel de confianza
para calcular estos intervalos sigue
siendo del 95% al ejecutar muchas
muestras seguiremos teniendo que
aproximadamente el 95% de las veces la
proporción verdadera de la población
estará contenida en el intervalo de
confianza por lo que aproximadamente el
5% de las veces esto no ocurrirá
nos vemos en otro vídeo